I'm David Thorburn director of the MIT
communications forum and professor of
literature at MIT this is the third and
final forum in our series will
newspapers survive and in a moment I
will introduce our three panelists and
talk briefly about our scheme for today
my hope is that our conversation will
genuinely be accretive that those icy
already many familiar faces and that as
more people straggle in we will actually
have a core audience who's been here for
all of the events unlike our speakers
who have not had the advantage of being
here and personal though I know that
they've been able to consult the website
and read read the text summaries and so
forth I wanted to begin by making a
couple of very brief comments of my own
about our series and about the way i
feel it's gone so far partly as an
incitement to our audience to to ask
pointed and and even perhaps aggressive
questions my colleague Brad see well who
was my indispensable right arm and keeps
the forum afloat suggested to me when we
were planning this event that the final
title for the third of our of our forums
why newspapers matter was somewhat
inappropriate and he said you should say
instead do newspapers matter and I
thought for a long time about this he's
probably right if you if you paid
attention if you paid attention to our
to our first two forums you might
actually feel especially that that was a
much more appropriate question why take
for granted that there are values in
newspapers that it must be defended or
articulated and I thought for a long
time about yielding to Brad's common
sense a suggestion but decided against
it perhaps out of nostalgia I nearly
became a newspaper man myself and when I
was at when I was in college I was I
served as the stringer for a whole
series of newspapers that I went to a
university midway between new york and
philadelphia and in the time i was an
undergraduate they were day there were a
very large number of daily newspapers in
both cities
and and the folks who worked in the
press club to which I belong were able
to serve all of these newspapers at
various times in my own life I have
served as a writer for now the
now-defunct New York Herald Tribune the
United Press International associated
The Associated Press the New York Times
and the experience working with grown-up
journalists I was just a college man at
the time was very instructive to me it
seemed to me that the journalists I
dealt with when I was a young man had a
particular passion for their work and a
particular sense of mission that
reminded me not of people who are out to
sort of make aliyah minded me of
teachers who do what they do mostly out
of love of the work not because they are
very well paid and I think that there is
still some tradition of that in American
journalism so in any case it may be a
kind of nostalgia in me that led to
insisting against my friend see Wells
advice that we keep the title why
newspapers matter my hope is that in
fact you we will try to answer that
question and if you doubt that
newspapers have any value at all I
encourage you to try to say that oh
thank you well I'll just step back a bit
I'm not sure how helpful that was see
well but will it will live with it what
what I want what I want what I want to
suggest though about the discourse we've
had so far to try to contextualize where
we stand out from from my own some
perhaps nostalgic and not disinterested
perspective might run something like
this it seems to me that the discourse
we've had so far has been to utopian
it's been too much in favor of the of
the new it has not been sufficiently
attentive to what newspapers have been
in American life to what they and and
maybe more broadly and culturally in
other societies generally and my hope is
that we will interrogate more
systematically and are at least in our
discussion and I know that our speakers
are going to address this question today
that we will interrogate really
systematically what it is about
newspapers at least in the past what
about the role of newspapers in society
that signifies that matters that is that
it that is there
distinctive and the particular way in
which I would raise not not total
hostile opposition but questions Dubai
it is about the kind of argument that
i'll call the utopians have been making
falls into two separate categories one
is you know certain sense ideological or
political and the other is cultural the
ideological or political problems it
seems to me is that it seems to me that
the people who talk about the excitement
of the new interactive technologies and
them and the magnificent possibilities
that are available to us and it will
become available in future because of
because of the internet and and and
other amazing likely outcomes that will
follow from our exploring the
possibilities of digital technology the
prime not that the vision of astonishing
possibilities is mistaken it's obviously
correct and there's no question at all
that these these these new these new
modes of communication have a
transformative and potentially morally
and politically revolutionary effect on
society of course that's that's obvious
although the revolution may be a very
long one may not be the right word to
use since cultural change takes time and
we might think of it as an evolutionary
process no one I think who's paid
attention would dispute that but it does
seem to me that the rhetoric of the
folks who talk about the transition
we're in and the Falls it makes at least
some easy assumptions that I want to
mention to you quickly and one of them
one of these easy assumptions has to do
with the with the value that is assumed
to in here in words like participatory
interactive and even the word democratic
this of course these are very important
categories but when you set those
categories up as if they are
unproblematic and is if every activity
which lacks a participatory dimension in
the way you define participation is
somehow inadequate then the game is over
before it begins of course newspapers
are less interactive than certain forms
of digital technology but the that
doesn't mean that they're not
interactive in some sense and nor does
it mean that every human activity needs
to have
interactivity in it it is certainly the
case that Shakespeare's plays do not
permit the same degree of interactivity
as certain forms of video games but it
doesn't follow from that that
Shakespeare is inferior to the
experience of video games so that the
issue the issue is not that
participatory or interactive dimensions
of communication technologies are not
valuable but but that they are not the
only value nor is the absence of these
qualities or the relative absence of
these qualities necessarily a source for
skepticism about the technology's forms
of communication that seem less
interactive more needs to be said about
these questions than simply to say well
this is interactive and this is not
there are there are forms of
interactivity that can actually be very
annoying and troublesome and unhelpful
to certain kinds of enterprises not all
enterprises have to be democratic right
so i think that there's an ideological
or political dimension to the to the
arguments that are that or to the
discussions that surround questions of
the sort that we're facing in this
series that need to be interrogated more
closely that we need to be more
skeptical and more rigorous about what
we mean by the interactive what we mean
by the participatory and we need to ask
questions about what what activities
most fundamentally require and are
benefited by participatory activities
and interactivity and what activities
may be needless interactivity or need an
interactivity of a different sort
because it isn't true of course that the
audience for Shakespeare's plays or the
reader of tolstoy's novels are not
interacting in the profoundest ways with
these old technologies with with but but
they are interacting in ways that are
different from the capacity to decide
what plot twist is coming next they are
not collaborators with the author in
quite the same way that certain kinds of
collaborative websites create genuine
forms of participation and collaboration
I hope it's clear that I'm not
suggesting that these forms of
collaboration or interaction are
negative or bad in any way I'm just
suggesting that to constantly to Ray to
say this form of communication this form
of news gathering is much more
interactive than
that is for me not to make a powerful
point about whether or not the older
form is less valuable or more valuable
the cultural aspect of this argument
also seems to me important and by that i
mean i think that there's been an
insufficient attention so far to what
might be called the ritual or embedded
cultural dimensions of newspapers
newspapers in the at least in the United
States and in many other countries offer
certain forms of experience that are
very difficult to find elsewhere and one
thing that quite apart from the question
of whether newspapers provide
information to people which of course
they do at some level they do other
things as well they organize the world
and they organize the world on a daily
basis and and and they they create a
universe that is in some sense more
fundamentally unified and coherent than
the atomistic universe we might find in
other communication systems and other
communication forms and and the way in
which newspapers organize the world and
the way in which they organize the world
every day anew is an experience that's
much more complex than we've yet given
attention to when you sit down on Sunday
morning with your partner to take the
New York Times or The Washington Post
apart and share out parts of it you're
you're engaged in a social behavior and
an interactive behavior with your
partners or your friends that's also
part of the ritual of using and reading
newspapers so it's important for us to
think about and and and and consider
other aspects of the experience of
newspapers of the way in which
newspapers have been institutionalized
and instantiated in American life in
order for us to get a real full sense of
what would be lost if newspapers
genuinely disappeared or if the aging of
the newspaper readership reached the
point that there were virtually no more
no more readers for newspapers and they
essentially except for certain great
national brands that were able to keep
themselves going essentially disappeared
as cultural forces finally I want to
suggest that there is a another overtly
political dimension to the role of
newspapers especially in American life
that we need to pay a little more
attention to than we have so far I'm
talking about the fact that newspapers
are operate under
the protection of the First Amendment
unlike other forms of communication and
that there is a long tradition of the
newspapers as a kind of independent
political observer who can stand up
against and and and sometimes even defy
the demands of government the loss of a
the loss of an institution of that kind
in any society would obviously be a
serious one we need to ask questions
about whether in the transition where
the long transition we're making from
paper to digital like to dip from a
paper world to a digital world from a
from a from front from a from a dead
tree technology to it to a digital
technology we need to ask questions of
that sort about the car whether or not
the new systems of communication and the
new systems of news gathering that are
going to emerge in our society in a
digital environment are going to offer
the kind of the kind of political and
and and and moral independence that at
least the ideal of certain newspapers in
the United States and the practice of
some newspapers certainly justifies well
that's my response to what we've done so
far I hope it's an incitement to the
audience to ask questions and to fight
argue not just with me but with other
speakers and even speakers who may not
even be here it's now my it's now my
great pleasure to introduce our speakers
and to explain our format they all of
our speakers have have a kindly agreed
to keep their arguments tight they're
going to make brief introductory
statements i'm going to time them
closely they'll stop after a relatively
short time we're going to try to
maximize our opportunity for
participation and interaction a value I
really do embrace of course are our
speakers starting starting here Pablo
butch offski is a is a professor in the
Department of Communication Studies at
Northwestern he many MIT folks know him
because he was here at MIT before moving
to northwestern is the author of a very
interesting book called digitizing the
news innovation in online newspapers and
his recent research which is going to
talk to us about deals with other
aspects of this topic in ways that I'm
excited about hearing Jerome Armstrong
in the middle although he'll be we're
going to talk in alphabetical order so
it'll be Jerome Pablo and Dante in that
in that order now what we go it's
Jerome's last name it's the a that makes
them go first Armstrong Armstrong is the
founder of netroots calm he's the
creator of the political blog my DD calm
and he's the author of co-author of
crashing the gate netroots grassroots
and the rise of people powered politics
finally Dante Chinni is the senior
research associate for in for the
project for Excellence in Journalism a
media columnist for The Christian
Science Monitor he's also served as a
reporter for the net on the national
affairs desk at Newsweek magazine we're
going to begin with Jerome Armstrong
proceed to Pablo than to Dante thank you
David hello everybody I'm going to do
these introductory remarks and from a
perspective of talking a little bit
about my interaction of I think how I bi
come into this discussion and then segue
from that and that would be mostly about
blogs and what I do a lot on the web and
then segue from that into the
interaction with blogs and other forms
of communications and how that interacts
with newspapers and then looking at some
questions and things for thoughts up for
the ensuing discussion so backing into
the subject from the perspective of
blogs I don't spend a lot of time
watching television or reading these
papers i might do when i go through an
airport pick one up to somebody's left
behind but the actual activity of
reading a newspaper for me has dropped
off tremendously in the over the last
decade i can remember a time this being
you know a month before the election
when i would go down and buy the new
york times the Boston Globe and scour
over them for the political news of the
day leading up to the elections well now
with the elections about a month away
what I would wind up doing is going out
in the blogosphere and reading about 30
different blogs and finding out all the
different polling information there and
everything as far as opinion wise would
come from the blogs so taking a step
back from all right how did this
happen well looking at from my
perspective and I'm a partisan Democrat
I work for Democratic candidates and
progressive the for me and a lot of
people like me what what we saw in the
early part of this decade was a lack of
a progressive voice in the mainstream
media outlets there was vile accounts
you know you can the right wing will say
that the the mainstream media is liberal
and orientation and they might be in
philosophy but I certainly don't
wouldn't adhere to the the belief that
the the mainstream media is democratic
in any way and so the rise of the blog's
was in large part a reaction to not only
a right-wing propaganda machine but also
the lack of progressive voices in the
establishment media the probably you can
point to a couple different events along
this path with the rise of the
progressive blogosphere and we'll get
i'll get to some numbers here in a
second but I first point out the the the
debacle that we had in florida in two
thousand next along line would be the
the boat by the democrats leading up
into the two thousand two midterms to
give Bush the permission to invade
occupy iraq and then the the phenomenon
of howard dean and the rises and net
roots and what's happening this last
cycle which is much more of a
decentralized effort of the local
blogosphere it's gotten to the point now
where that how many blogs are there well
there's there's millions of blogs
according to technorati but if you look
at the the top tier blogs in terms of
the numbers its increased in size since
2003 by a hundred times the liberal blog
add or edit the liberal blog ad network
is it comprises about a hundred of the
leading blogs and it received over 120
million pageviews in this last month and
that represents probably around 15
million people that are actively engaged
in it these people are very politically
active among self-identified Democrats
23% in a recent hotline poll visit the
blogs on a regular basis and they tend
to vote to the pew pew study
post-election 2004 found that 99% of
those interviewed that were Dean
supporters voted so this is a minority
even by accounts of participation within
the Democratic
universe they are very strong in terms
of their their opinions and their
partitions a participation in the in the
political process stepping away from the
political blogs in the overall blog
readership right now according to a
recent survey by the blog ads is at
about 50 million and those blogs
transpire every sort of you know topic
you can imagine anybody's interest that
they basically have they will go to a
blog and a lot of people well and and
find those interest in being able to
congregate talk about it with other
people the relationship between blogs
and other sorts of mediums is symbiotic
from my experience and a lot of what I
see on the on the internet is it's not
that a lot of content is generated by
blogs bloggers themselves but they will
go to more traditional media sites such
as the newspaper online newspapers and
portal sites MSNBC CNN those type of
things and they will they will feed off
those right their opinions off it but
it's also it goes both ways you have a
lot more journalists now who write for
print and online that go to the blogs to
find out what's the recent stories that
are breaking blogs are sort of you know
they've busted open the gateway that
used to be there for media but now there
are in many ways a place for people to
try out opinions are leads and see if
they can gain traction in the wider
sphere let me present a couple different
statements here on the relationship of
blogs and newspapers so first is by
Corby Parnell and talking about the
difference between news and opinions new
he says newspapers are dying medium
however blogging will not be the cause
of its death normal blogs replace
newspapers as a primary source of news
for majority of the world's population
fair and balanced journalism is good
journalism when I seek out news I don't
read Robert Novak instead I read The
Associated Press on the whole individual
bloggers will never consistently produce
the kind of original highly refined
unbiased content that even small town
newspaper readers have come to expect in
value however the thought energy that
bloggers put into their reporting and
news aggregation efforts can and will be
leveraged by other participating mediums
such as wikinews and will therefore
contribute to and hasten the demise of
the newspaper
medium of course it's also possible that
the newspaper medium will survive by
aggregating good content from the blogs
and that particular that last point that
he makes it is is something that I've
seen happened more and more blogs like
any other medium once it once they reach
a certain threshold of communication
possibility the commercialisation are
enters into it because it costs more to
run those things the the convergence in
of newspapers adapting to blogs involves
the commercialization of those blogs
there's another quote here the the
Arizona Republic the Des Moines Register
and the San Jose Mercury News were among
a group of publishers that signed up for
blog birds to blog syndication service
under the terms of the agreement
newspapers can publish any of more than
1,500 blogs featured by the service and
how this works is that you know if
somebody writes a review of something
locally our state covers a sports story
those can syndicate right into the into
the newspapers if they have that
agreement set up and won a quote here is
from the American state statesman in
Austin they offer tools on this website
that enable readers to create their own
blogs which can then be posted on the
papers website since starting the later
service since late-september the
newspapers seen readers create / 108
hundred seventy-five blogs there's about
twenty five hundred page views a day he
the Austin statesman acknowledges the
blog's have yet to attract huge
audiences but the point is to offer
readers a chance to connect with
like-minded folks the idea behind this
to create more of a community you can
create community and you'll increase
traffic and loyalty to me that's a
really interesting statement because it
points to why I believe why blogs have
have arisen in across the whole
stratification of different interests
and stuff I mentioned why you know one
reason why i thought the political blogs
have arisen but it really doesn't
explain the whole wider phenomenon of
blogging in general but i think what
this what this person is pointing to is
in the in the sense of community that
offers we need to ask the question just
is with that sense of community the
blogs are creating is that replacing
something that newspapers offered or is
it offering
something that newspapers haven't
offered if we segue from that into
looking at this period as a transition
period and in particularly recognizing
the niche media's that have been created
by the Internet in reaction to what I
would call the broadcast medium yeah
okay the broadcast effort of the last
century if you look at the over the last
in last century there's been basically
the print medium then radio then
television which has been the broadcast
the means of getting out your message to
a large number of people and you have
basically a one-to-many message delivery
someone would formulate the message
it'll get delivered out through the
broadcast mediums the whole
fragmentation that's happened of that
structure over the last couple decades
is is points towards what's going to
happen in the future the the means of
delivering your message now is become
much more niche much more one-to-one
marketers figure out how to how to
identify you through data mining and
such forth and deliver your message to
you in much more compelling matter how
the only way it's really effective to
reaching now in terms of mass delivery
is to get a wide adoption of your
message by many people who will then
forward on to their networks because
people have basically lost touch a lot
of them with those broadcast mediums so
this is a basic some overriding
questions that I have here in terms of
the newspapers in their relevancy are
they going to be able to customize their
content in a way that can be compelling
as online news services are you have
much more easier ability now to go out
and get your niche media in the online
capacity than you do on the broadcast
it's you know you have your a ones page
on the newspaper is that more compelling
that's authoritarian line and you
capture basically an interest that
response to your likes and dislikes
immediately that's my two minutes ten
minutes and thank you
of the project a couple of months ago I
was there and I had to give similar to
the first stop on this project so it was
297 actually and I wanted to check what
the papers that I had been studying one
report and in particular how the front
page is ruler what you see here are the
front pages of the top two national
print newspapers in Argentina combined
market share fifty percent of the
national newspaper market the top
newspaper yo Kareem is thirty-four
percent sure the national labor market
the second one Lana see on is fifty
percent sure what you see is that the
top national story about the national
government in your body is the same top
national story place exactly the same
position in its competitor the top
foreign story one has fallen in his bowl
on Israel which is also the top so the
top story for the top one newspaper the
top story for the second newspaper also
place in somewhat similar position then
top sort of local news about a massive
brain that I happened the day before is
also share
the two newspapers is the story that has
the most prominent visual loss permanent
photo picture more or less of the same
car destroyed and then finally the top
health science medicine story is shared
by both so basically what you have here
is the top two newspapers in the entire
country fifty percent of the market
share for the entire print industry on
the particular they share in basically
most of their front pages now it is a
group or not this an outlier testicle
incident is part of a larger trend these
paperless research are you done it is
hard of a larger and larger trend that
has a lot to do with certain technical
practices certain ways in which the web
has been used in the past 45 years to
provide breaking news throughout the day
has actually learned in an unintended
manner to a growing convergence of
content sharing of content thematic
overlap not just a mind on that
newspapers but in the entire media space
to particular in pre and so what this
type of tries to do is to try to show
this critically and to understand world
role certain technical practices play in
this phenomenon it does this through a
Content analysis of both free and online
newspapers in Argentina the results very
quickly heart that over a ten-year
period there has been a systematic
growth in the sharing or the overlap of
content among print newspapers
coinciding a lot with intensification of
publishing constant breaking news online
during the day right that this cycle
over a ten-year period for bring repeats
itself over a 24-hour period for online
right you take online newspapers out in
your midnight on our menus papers 23 and
a half hours later you see a convergence
of their news agenda and then what we
have today is in
very dense web of content homogeneity
content overlap in the entire media
aspect spectrum so what I would like to
do at the end of it after presenting
basically bit more this is to draw some
conceptual entrances in pathological
implications and since they asked me to
make sure that I would have something
very direct to say about the content of
the same real implications for this
insane now a nun say that the end of it
are as I see very simple so the question
is why my newspapers matter less than
before because they have themselves
commodified their hard news content they
have commodified one of their main
contributions right commercial product
also in society right contributions to
apology to a public sphere and they have
they made matter less and a moment even
less in the future because this
decreases their power in terms of
setting the agenda and also tell this
decreases and contribution to diverse
public sphere in society I won't worry
with political implications of the
grounding general one quick thing to say
and that motivates the overall project
of these papers and among my colleagues
sociologist of media has been a lot of
thought about the strength that more and
more media resembles each other but this
one has not be accompanied with a lot of
systematic research any particular
research that looks at things and things
unfolding over time and across media so
in the house of comparative Media
Studies you don't work that Henry Dailey
and William happy doing overtime I can't
lose particularly important to emphasize
that one needs to look at this
phenomenon relationally and over time
which it should be special tries to do
couple things about the artist and
context so that you understand so the
overall basis of the cervical decision
of the u.s. like first the penetration
of the internet in the year in which
data for the
collected last year for twenty-five
percent of the population so it's not a
massive name is still a medium for today
secondly the newspaper use the Untied
industry in the state is not local it's
national one second is highly
concentrated talk to players on fifty
percent of the market 12-5 on to third
percent to two-thirds of the market
65-percent roughly second unlike the
u.s. they shared the advertising hi of
the newspaper industry help you make
more or less constant over the past ten
years and even though Argentina suffer
some of you may know a massive economic
crises in a one to one day if she hasn't
covered by handsomely for instance in
the past year when newspapers in the
states were five people left and right
the top newspaper energy TM made salary
increases across the board for all its
personnel amounted to thirty-five
percent salary raises but we took a turn
for inflation but partly because
business is good so this is your
happening in the context in which
business is bad resources administration
it's actually by the conference so
because of characters three newspapers
the top player top player for print come
play for life relative to the size of
the country 40 million people the top
play is a fairly large newspaper if you
basically mean we adjusted to the size
of the state I mean add a simulation of
three million and a signed receipt
relation of six million and is the
second largest newspaper previous rating
the Spanish league in were second and is
also with the top online newspapers as
well second character the second largest
finish paper and also the similar
paper sir kya at least like a week in
the print work it's a very small
financial thirty-one percent of the
market so we are going to look at it for
print but I looked at it for a line
because it has become over the past 34
years a very very strong competitor like
partly because of its a classic
practices of publishing online use
constantly throughout the day the final
thing to keep in mind is that in all
these cases organizationally we have to
neutral we don't have one do some share
so it's not the usual one organization
shared from these two organizations
sharing and for the top player they are
apart you know basically miles apart
from each other my future so really
there are two different organization
okay quick thing about the recent design
i looked at the front pages of the top
two previous papers and a good balance
online the first screen so the top nine
stories basically formats on free online
newspapers for bring over a ten-year
period for online over a 24-hour cycle
for free I look at four videos right
over these ten years first in 1995
immediately before they are all night
counterparts starting to balance of my
baseline then in two thousand
immediately before the only counterfeit
stamping polish breaking updates during
the day for the first five years
blackmailing newspapers in the States
this one is papers basically took the
free content of holding on the computer
so I want me to see whether their very
existence but not the practice of
punishing online have made any
difference and then sorry no one decided
to publish more and more breaking news
during the day and in particular in 2004
they move very easily
greenasaur my third and four data points
come from basically half a year after
they move aggressively to publishing
online and Ian at this is what I found
that between 1995 and 2000 right there
is no difference in between the front
pages of the newspapers of five years of
existence of the online edition has made
no difference however when online
started like you polish aggressively
that actually made a difference for
print basically in 1995 and 2000 the
tools in these two samples one in Philly
hard news stories where share however
when we go to the all four and on 512
and about the same with a small growth
between 0 405 raising the possibility
right at this train is going upward
secondly of the stories that we share
these 12 impacts more healthy public
after stories but eighteen percent more
sharing of politics basically national
fuel quality local politics economics
and foreign secondly i looked at
evolution during the day at three points
in time of the day mid-morning once the
folks in the online you some had time to
provide sort of basically more more
stories for the online edition in the
middle afternoon and at the end of the
day and then this this was for online i
love that we follow the sprints edition
of the top two newspapers to see where
the world any relation basic findings
first saw the basin the basic level of
shared stories is already very high
unlike print so we start with basically
wanting to be in share however between
the morning early afternoon there is no
major significant statistically
significant change however in evening
that race is four percent which is from
a basin of you know almost 40 basically
nine percent per person is quite a lot
is never gonna go much higher than done
so basically we see a thematic
convergence in the new
agenda right unfolding in real time
doing a 24 hour cycle unlike praying
thematically this affects far more non
public affair stories which is basically
on the following orders [ __ ]
entertainment and crime finally one
thing we looked at is if we take the
evening edition of online 10pm and the
following day edition right of print
basically if it reaches consumers eight
hours later how many of the stories that
I have imprinted in day to have been
anticipated by a Dewar's on more online
between fifty and sixty percent within
each newspaper and a lot of cross
anticipation which tells me that they
said as I said really very dense work of
shared content among the top two players
in the country which have far more than
fifty percent of political power to sell
the news agenda so water is me one that
technology and certain technical
practices are essential to understand
what's going on but it's known
technology percent changes how
technologies use five years of having
online didn't make any difference for
train was only after line began to be
used for certain purposes that that
ended up affecting the general face
secondly and again the house of
comparative Media Studies a relational
less critical to understand what's going
on in today's media environment is
impossible to just focus on praying all
online television we need to understand
the relationship of this and finally why
why do I make so much all technology
before you in this study I spent
together a team of researchers in
Argentina nine months inside an illusion
of the top player here and one of the
things that we found is that there is an
a great intensification of the
monitoring
people in the newsroom of what their
competitors are doing and what the
entire media environment looks like at
any given point in time that is
reporters editors I've always looked at
the competition now they look at the
division with five minutes every 10 mins
obsessively all the time they look all
the time and they have the mandate of
having a very complete picture of the
day's news so if they see in their
competitors something that they don't
have but their bosses are not going to
be happy so basically then take that
story and policy as well but still on
the home page like so what that means is
that over the course of the day
everybody started having the same news
right so breaking news all the time
online basically as is the power of
access to the information about the
competitors and what that has meant
right in fact that has increased the
process documentation and the level of
Shere Khan de la noche anything in the
problem just to give you a little bit of
the tail reporters monitor to make sure
that they have a complete picture of the
editor of two minutes as the editor of
the economics section of this Sunday
newspaper said I look to be other online
music all the time I do not release any
interpreter if something has released a
puddin so the editor of the herb and it
said if a piece of use that has been
published like a competition then we
launched on to publish perhaps it is not
very important so we lower you to put
your mother part of the home page bubble
puppy sit anyway if they have it we have
to have it too and they monitor before
and after the puppies before the
coverage to calibrate the framing of the
story right so talking about the
high-profile story one reported on
politics section natural
because so unless looking at the
competition is unavoidable when we
define the header and the little fish
story before we publish the first thing
we did was to check out our competitors
to see their friend we do this almost
automatically and after they publish to
assess their performance visa it also
tell competitor so what is that this is
from one of the three laws at 630pm a
local cable news channel announces and
relatives of the Michael Jackson prior
which triggers an intense rush in the
newsroom to publish the story seven
minutes later because this is very very
very fast the updated story is found the
editor looks immediately at the size of
their competitor sunset we publish it
first the home page table congratulating
shakes his hand and says something along
the lines of great work all right
methodology I won't bother you again why
my newspapers mattered less than before
because they have their cells
commodified why the distinctive
contributions to society arguing in runs
the risk of decreasing their power to
set their gender and ability to
contribute to diverse public sphere you
might think this is under titillation
many cases of where country girl there
in the wheel son but acid functional
protocol for the excellence in
journalism send in the set of news media
for 2006 the new paradox of American
journalism is more outlets coming here
stories
I guess the the first thing I'd point
out just on what Pablo just said is that
we're some colleagues of mine are coming
out with a book on local television news
that shows that actually local
television news the United States the
homogeneity is it's breathtaking it's
it's frightening but hey if you watch
local TV news you know that already
right uh first first let me thank thank
David for having me here at MIT the
website for this forum said that it was
going to have media critics working
journalists and online visionaries for
the record I'm a member of the first two
camps I'm not a member of the third camp
but seeing as I'm from Washington and
visionaries are in short supply down
there I'm happy to be here but when we
started before we start just want to do
a couple things just again idea of your
your media consumption habits and this
is probably not an average audience even
by the highly area died standards of
Greater Boston but how many of you in
the last two days read a newspaper for
news okay how many of you got some news
from local or national television news
or cable news okay how many of you went
to a big website New York Times CNN com
boston.com and how many of you went to a
blog for news and the point of this is
that it look our media consumption
habits are increasingly very complicated
okay we're we're all omnivores now okay
we're media omnivores we go all over the
place for our news and the way to look
at this kind of this moment in history
right now and I think I hope moments to
come is this is a very good time be a
news consumer it's the best you can go
umpteen places for news national and
international and you really control
your news diet if you want to spend the
day on ESPN you know just reading and
knowing every little bit of my new show
about sports you can if you want to go
to BBC calm you can do that if you want
to go and scatter around you can do that
too but this is also a difficult time to
be a news consumer because all that
all those possibilities mean that you
really have to monitor your diet closely
it's really easy to kind of wander down
the news junk food aisle and just stuff
your mouth of Ho Hos if that's what you
want to do it's possible and whether or
not newspapers survive or not I actually
think this is going to continue to be
the case I think we're going to be
continued we're going to be a mixed
we're going to be omnivores we're going
to be getting a little bit from
different places a little bit from here
a little bit from there I don't I I
completely agree with Jerome about blogs
I don't think I think it's wrong to
think that blogs are going to replace
newspapers but I think that you know
they make the news environment richer I
think there's no question about that but
the idea that top-down media is just
going to suddenly disappear with you
know assignment desks or their
equivalent and reporters and editors and
people touching your people a lot of
hands on the copy before you see it I
think that's going to continue its just
going to live alongside other things the
question of whether in my opinion
question of whether newspapers are going
to survive is obviously a provocation I
mean it's it's you know it's it's such a
broad question that you know the answer
is yes in some sense i think newspapers
will survive i don't know what they're
going to look like i don't know if
they're going to be on paper I don't
know what they're going to cover
topically or geographically and I think
the biggest question is I don't know how
they're going to fund the coverage that
they do there are real challenges in all
those fronts newsprint as you probably
know is expensive and delivery of the
newspaper is not the most efficient you
know system in the world a kid coming by
and thrown a paper at your door is it's
nice I get my newspaper that way but
it's not the most efficient way of
getting the newspaper metro areas and
this is important I think for local news
are harder to cover than ever because
they sprawl you know you know greater
boston extends to New Hampshire so how
does the Boston Globe cover all that
that it's gets it gets very complicated
I mean it those people up there may want
the boston globe because they want the
national news but can they really feel
they're getting the local news they need
in there it's a very it's complicated
it's very difficult for the globe or for
any big metro daily to do that and on
top of all this revenues are down in
newspapers and they continue to go I
mean they're they're they're inching
slightly upward but there
if you look at it over you know
long-term they were going like this
they're creeping up now and that's for a
lot of reasons one of them is falling
readership which I'm sure we all know
about the best-case scenario for
newspaper readership over the coming
years is a one is a slow and steady one
percent decline for newspapers that's
the best-case that's what we're hoping
for how does the web fit in all this it
hurts and it helps obviously you know
more eyes see the content from
newspapers and this is good thing the
bad parts there are a lot of them online
is killing newspapers where classified
ads are concerned that was a steady
stream of income that's gone all those
people who read the newspaper for free
it's it's not clear that it's a large
number yet it's somewhere about I think
six or seven percent that don't that
read it but read it online but don't get
it delivered or read the hard copy
that's money that's lost in terms of
subscription revenue one thing we cite
in report is if online and print ad
rates stay where they are you know it's
if the idea that the well online
revenues will increase at some point
it'll be a nice stream of money and
it'll be able to fund all that wonderful
reporting you get it's it's it's hard
our estimates are somebody else's
estimates we count on our if they stay
where they are if rates stay where they
are they would have to grow at a rate of
thirty three percent till the year 2017
just to make up for where things are
right now that means that you know it's
going to be hard times for all in the
newspaper industry and that brings us to
the big question so what what if there
were no more newspapers and we'll get
into this tonight and I think actually
that just hearing people talk there's
more agreement on this then then you
might think but I'll throw out a few
things well I think newspapers are
critical newspapers are at the lat at
the local and the national level the
place with the most bodies it's got the
most it's the newspaper that has the
most reporters on the street more it
there may be more people that watch
local TV news but in terms of
having people out there getting the news
it's the newspaper that has the most
people what does that mean that means
that they have beat reporters who have a
certain amount of expertise and who know
what the heck they're talking about I
there there's some feeling among
bloggers and I know because I right
things and I right thanks my column and
I have an email where people can get in
touch with me and you'd you know you get
flames from people through the email I
think blogs actually do a pretty good
job of covering big stories and it's for
the for the reason Jerome was saying I
think that they basically blogs largely
feed off what's out there they take the
news that's out there they tell you what
they think of it maybe they poke holes
in it maybe it's another set of eyes
that has problems with something that's
out there but the store is already out
there they're not very good at breaking
something they're not going to break
news and that's because you know they're
not bloggers aren't going to be walking
around the Justice Department you know
for free okay they should have to give
up whatever they do and like well I'm
just going to go you know stand over at
the Department of Interior for a while
and see what I pick up and then put it
on my blog because nobody's going to
read that it's only interesting when
something happens at the Department of
the Interior but to know what's really
going on you have to have somebody there
to figure it out unfortunately
increasingly newspapers don't have those
people there because of staff cuts and
that's an issue number two I think
despite all the grumblings about bias
from the left and right in newspaper and
I think some of it you know that's
that's par for the course you know the
those lovable mainstream journalists do
at least try to get the story straight I
do think they're trying to get the story
straight I don't think they willingly
spin readers I think they get spun I
think that happens and I think it's
going to happen all the time they're
human beings it's going to continue but
if you think that well okay so we'll go
with bloggers will go citizen
journalists as a replacement of
newspaper people or replacement of
newspapers you know they cover what they
cover a lot of times because a they're
there they care very deeply about the
issue and they would like to see it turn
out one way or the other which means
they're going to have a certain thing
they'd like to say or certain spin
they'd like to put on it or sometimes I
actually have a dog in the fight and
there's nothing wrong with that as long
as you know it but
you end up with that that's what
everybody starts doing is you have a
world full of electronic equivalents of
the nation or or the National Review and
I think that's interesting I just think
it can't be the sole way we get news you
know that you know if that was the world
whether you sit on the left or the right
at some point you'd have to wonder you
know where the truth lies or especially
if you sit in the middle in other words
there's something be said for the
pursuit of objectivity 3 and this is a
big one and this goes to what David was
saying early on because in this comeback
the beginning because the news
environment is so complicated now and
because we're all omnivores you need
somebody to make sense of it you need a
guide now that doesn't mean that you
have to take their you don't you don't
have to take their vision of everything
at face value don't have to say well the
most important story of the day is
marked Foley because the New York Times
said it was most important story of the
day but at some point you're probably
interested to find out what a bunch of
people who just look at the news all the
time and go through the stories and try
to figure out what the biggest news of
the day is you're probably curious to
see what they think it is maybe after
you go and look at the things in
particular that you're interested in the
strength of a newspaper is really its
collective knowledge it's all these
people who may not be experts in areas
but who have who have knowledge in them
and I you know I may know more or you
may know more than your favorite or
least favorite reporter about the thing
that you care about but collectively the
newspaper actually has a lot of
knowledge that they can put together in
mind to try to figure out what's really
important every day I'll stop because I
want to stay short but I want to put one
important cabin on all this while we're
talking about newspapers I think it's
important to have to get caught up in
the paper aspect of it the important
thing is that somebody is doing these
things that I just talked about and it
may be that it's going to end up being
electronic it may be some other some
other form that it comes to you by but
the delivery system to me isn't
important what's really important is
providing the things that we talked
about and I think I think most important
finding an economic model that really
makes that possible because right now
the economic now model for online is
there's just there's a lot of stuff out
there
but there isn't funding really to have
the reporters to have the base of
reporters you'd need to go out and kind
of gather news you want their newspaper
and let's just leave it at that and do
what you have to say this is the
audience's turn I count on your being
articulate and concise come down to
these two microphones if you have
questions or comments not just questions
we welcome your your argumentative sides
as well as as well as well as questions
I thought while you're sort of gathering
your thoughts I thought I might give
each of the panelists a chance to
respond quickly to what they heard their
colleagues say those public let's start
with you do you have any responses that
you'd like to offer actually making
money and profit margins that are much
higher than those of their cream
counterpart the problem is that the
volume it is very good so we are talking
about a business that a services will be
satisfactory for most entrepreneurs by
disqus especially for a very large
company and company that has been used
to enjoy an incredibly handsome profit
margin right with very very much boredom
for a long time right right so and
that's because several years ago to
produce is here now it's making magic of
the work with news but now they are
making money
you money proportional speaking the
program is the size right right on there
and a lot of times they're getting their
content from there you know they're
drawing the content from the from the
print side yeah Dante let's be sure when
you speak that it picks up the micro
turn the mic toward you when you speak
so make sure we get it on recording yeah
let me cut content on the commodified
nature of the news i think is really
interesting because it's sort of
corollary to what i was bringing up of
what you know a progressive might feel
earlier this decade is the non non not
enough representation of their their
viewpoints and i think it it's something
that that we can probably criticize
newspapers in general as lacking in in
that commercialization of that
commodification of it points to the lack
which I pointed out at the end of the
talk I gave which is community and
that's another reason why people are
turning to other sources other than
newspapers the the authority aspect is
there is a really interesting model
because you know what their I think
there's actually a little more breakdown
we need to do with that is that you have
authorities of people who are
like-minded with you people you turn to
as sort of an ally and then you have
authority figures that that society puts
up as relating to the general
information flow that that we go into
and I think newspapers are more of the
latter and typically those are the
things that are being deconstructed more
and more as people turn to more of the
former getting it online and blogs are
great representation of that of people
being able to form their own authority
leaders and their own networks their
their shared with other community
members just a touch on that i mean i
agree i think that when you're talking
about particularly about politics where
I think blogs are very strong there's
knowledge out there and then in those in
those blogs that that that maybe the
reporter doesn't have what I'm trying to
say about what the newspaper does have
is for you to get everything you get in
the newspaper or from a from a major
media organization it's a big reporting
staff is you'd need to go to a blog
about politics then you need to go to a
bog about what asian affairs and you
need to go to a blog
what's going on Europe then you need to
go to a blog about what's going on
health care then you it's very
complicated the thing the newspaper does
is it takes all these people aggregates
them in one place and I think if you
have specific areas of interest yeah
you're going to go to blogs and you're
going to get you you know if you want
in-depth political coverage I think a
lot of times you can get some of it on
the newspaper but I think yeah you're
going to go to blogs to supplement that
I just think you know the idea that we'd
all go through you know a blog for every
kind of topic in the newspaper it'd just
be it's just too damn time consuming
question here I want to pick up on that
point and the point mr. Tinney that you
made towards the end which is that even
if you get rid of the form of the
newspaper you didn't have a newspaper
and you didn't have delivery trucks and
you didn't have ink and everything else
you would still have enormous value in
the resources of the newspaper that no
blog can replicate and it seems to me
what's happening at least in some cases
is that newspapers are migrating into an
electronic format I read The Wall Street
Journal every day but I haven't picked
up the newspaper itself in weeks I read
it online because it's organized that
way no blog can can replace the wall
street journal but but the electronic
format is quickly replacing the
newspaper format it seems to me and I
wonder if you or the other panelists
would sort of talk about this middle
area that's not the traditional
newspaper but certainly not a blog it's
the newspaper that is delivered in the
in an electronic format well really
quickly I mean the journal is an
interesting example because it has one
huge advantage that most of the other
online newspapers own it charges for
content and it's in its in its such a
specialized and made people the journal
means something special people get it
and they feel they get they're going to
pay that you know the other the only you
know the times is kind of crept into it
by asking you to pay for colonists which
surprisingly has worked I've be honest
I've never thought that would work but
they're actually they've done pretty
well with it and they offer some
archival
stuff and things like that you know the
question is I do think I do think the
newspaper is going to migrate that way
and then I also think at some point I'd
be curious to hear what the other panels
off but you know video these things are
going to it's all going to merge there
will be there will be a some kind of
great convergence down the road it's
already if you talk to photographers at
newspapers they're being given video
cameras they don't shoot as much anymore
they take video and the quality they're
able to do frame grabs from the video
they shoot that's so good they don't
need the camera anymore so what does
this do well it a still can run the
photos in the online edition but they
also have this video of the event that
they can put out that actually can makes
them compete a little bit with
television it anyway I do think it's
moving that way I just think it's a
question of a discussion of finding way
to pay for it for the outlet well what
it brings out to me is like what are we
going to drop off if we if we know
what's going to left in the the waste
bakit of basket of history if newspapers
stopped in put in the paper format and
specifically because we're replacing it
online in the digital format is
increasingly what's going to happen
what's going to drop off is this
structured format of how the news is
presented to everybody and it has been
this one-size-fits-all model with the
paper newspaper that is ending and I
don't think there's any way that that's
going to get turned back even the
newspapers that people are going to be
getting at a certain point here it's
going to be like that Harry Potter movie
where you know you unroll something and
it's all digital in it it's just like a
digital paper that changes in the
delivery of these things day to day is
going to become a relic I don't think
that's a that that seems to me every ear
revocable change it's going to happen
the online news vehicle that people are
going to use is also becoming to come
more and more customized according to
your delivery that even the Wall Street
Journal they can find out more and more
about you and deliver the ads that they
want you to see based upon your consumer
profile that's not a trend that's going
to stop either so the thing that you
know I believe is that is really what
newspapers symbolize here that is going
to change is just one size fits all
broadcast medium
sumption that's represented most
dramatically with the online culture as
far as how it's changing the transition
from print to online you don't say the
same content I'm putting a different
delivery vehicle because the times and
places and modes of consumption rather
than the ways in which users readers
engage with a different media are
different what has been happening over
the past 45 years is that most of the
news online gets consumed doing regular
work hours if you look that right the
evolution of the traffic over 24 hour
cycle right it is flat more or less from
the wee hours in the morning until eight
or nine in the morning that starts to go
up right and it stays very high up until
five or six when it goes down so Pablo
if the implication is instead of working
people are going online to read the
newspaper so people are working with
computers are working online they're
taking the news but then do something
else they have very little time right so
right they on the consumer side there
are many things the attention is divided
they won't quit some bites or so the
common wisdom says on the journalistic
side then is that you're constantly urge
to feel right the consumers with
information so you don't have two hours
to go to a particular neighborhood to
source your story talk come back think
about it right give it to your copy
editor etc so that you have 20 minutes
from start to finish in the reasons I
was referring to when we spend nine
months inside this on a newspaper one
thing we look at what time of production
right from start to finish ninety-five
percent of the stories were producing
less than half hour now what this means
is that and there are many other things
having to do with a different medium
people use video audio etc but this
means is an integer
decision from these two these the way of
the ways of crafting a story change what
kinds of stories we can tell change like
how we tell those stories how the
stories are consumed appropriated
circulate in the blocks here all that
changes right so newspapers are in part
print but they also stand for certain
ways of journalism certain ways of in
which the media contribute to society
and that's in part what is in question
in this transition but not just it's not
as though instead of getting it here I
get it here question here you said on
can we hear her in the back can you hear
the speaker ask again it always seems
like well a new technology that meets
all these criteria i use google desktop
and google homepage and there's news
feed their email new sticker on top my
google desktop which is always up on the
sidebar peter has do story time you
choose to click a link where i won and
to me that's very much likes communities
and so the only thing that might be
different is my google that stuff looks
a little different than someone else's
in their new stories might be different
but I mean I live with my boyfriend his
parents for a while and we had three
newspapers arrived every morning all
four of us spend a couple hours with
them and yet if we were going to talk
about what we read in the paper United
before of us actually read the same
thing than before but identified as
being the same paper unless we actually
sat down and breton story aloud and my
google desktop I can either create a
lottery boyfriend or just emailed link
someone I want so the communal aspect
will be there and if that's not a
newspaper or not some form of a
newspaper or some baby form of what
might replace today's paper what is the
newspaper very difficult question well I
think I think a newspaper that's what I
mean we can't get we can't get caught up
in the idea that a newspaper a newspaper
is an organization full of people that
put out a product that you read every
day that's really what a newspaper is a
newspaper really isn't the isn't the
newsprint that gets on your fingers and
all that stuff google news is
interesting because i like google news a
lot but but google news couldn't exist
without the mainstream media it just
goes in and grabs stories and i think
it's very interesting i like it you know
and and i have a couple of RSS feeds and
you know but it but it's cannibalizing
you know it's taking stories from the
old media okay and it's and it's giving
them to you in a new format but it's
still denied to me that's still you know
the newspaper or or if you're getting it
from a broadcast company it's bright
it's you know it's ABC years CNN it's
got a really good point cuz I'm Dante I
mean it's because the newspapers I mean
Google couldn't exist with that I'll of
that thing to it could not exist if
people like Dante we're not on the
street you know doing the reporting not
on the street okay
I he's a columnist he's a pining now but
literally I mean you know so I I think
you have to probably step back and
unfold that well if Google's not really
supporting that model financially and
they're not they're just feeding off it
that's the point truth and so are a lot
of aggregators online what's going to
keep that model profitable and up and
standing for them to feed off it there's
there's no commercialization happening
between Google and everything that links
to it just is important and relevant
question of orissa newspaper newspaper
in addition to mention this paper is an
organization that specializes in
editorial judgment and selecting from
all the potential events happening
inside 24 hours or week the time which
ones are newsworthy and of those that
are used work which kind of fun with
etcetera etcetera google has an
algorithm so difference between Google a
newspaper is that there is nobody
actually looking at these 30 vs that so
it's an algorithm that selects of the
basis of certain criteria what kind of
news get delivering what kind of
position on the home plate what is
interesting is that that kind of
reasoning the mixing of the human and
the software is also happening at
regional newspaper so princess Lomond as
an in-house build software that assists
its editors online to select and rotate
the stories on its side during the day
depending on the number of patterns
issues and to do with traffic what
stories get you know more traffic than
that move up automatically or that
suggested to the editors as a shiver up
etc etc so I lose paper number this is
an organization that specializes in
editorial decision making part of the
transformation that is happening from
print online is that data eternal
decision making in part is being done in
conjunction with software but written in
part with a literal premises but where
theater premises are very much
from the beginning and with the human
element of reacting in an improvised way
and having that sort of feeling for the
news right disappears so that's another
important thing to keep in mind the
current context I have a question about
the economic model it sounds like
everyone's trying to we know that their
big change is happening but we don't
know what the economic model is going to
look like and I'm curious about your
thoughts on if one thing that's hurting
newspapers is the move to online another
it seems to me is the sort of
expectations about revenue newspapers
were wonderful investments for a while
when they were generating twenty percent
Wall Street love them and so a lot of
them are now public companies that
clearly is difficult to maintain and you
see some conversations happening now
about taking them private or taking them
in the hands of local investors who
wouldn't have that same expectations and
I'm just curious your thoughts how that
would affect this the pressures there in
with that allow would sort of stave off
some of these changes or would that give
them some breathing room to live a
little longer
so one and it's particularly relevant
for the American context is the critical
role of the capital markets unlike an
experience with this business with
companies in other countries considered
America where they still remain
privately owned mostly found in your own
enterprises right so they are sheltered
much more complications in the
marketplace newspapers in the States
decided two decades ago to fund
expansion through the capital markets
and that was wonderful for a certain
period of time but the capital markets
have certain sort of dynamics and that
day is a very short term view of
performance and that is hurting the
newspapers now because they are not
performing as well as other competitive
remarkably well who one compares that
with other of mature industry but
they're not performing as well as some
competitors so it is important in terms
of economic model years to think about
what are the consequences of the
important presence of the capital
markets in the industry and what could
be done or do not be done people for one
the other thing that I think it's
important to keep in mind that is the
way I think about this issue and another
expedition it's been some time thinking
about newspapers in general is that a
century ago that is known 1860 said the
traditional media own a lot by this very
significant portion of the information
environment and there were few conveys
which owns a lot now traditional media
I'm no no longer do no longer have this
dominant position in information the
market value of Google or some of the
new competitors far surpasses that of
many traditional companies even join we
put together so in a sense what has
happened is that newspapers as one
expression of national media in general
receded in their position in the market
place right in information marketplace
because the things that we used to do
separate me in the past now very well
together we get our news to search
online watch video we get moving
it will all do that in the convergent
some information environment so what
impart is hurting those papers is the
fact that overall they have a much less
controlling position of the entire
information environment and they have
much less room to maneuver in that sense
yeah I have a comment as somebody who
reads who reads the globe in paper and
The Times Online and pays for both
because I think I ought to pay for it my
concern isn't the change in technology I
don't care whether it's on paper or its
online but I care a lot about interface
I mean coincidentally I'm an interface
designer but but the role of serendipity
I have just two examples on the rare
case when I pick up the new york times
on paper and i read it a leaf through
and i will see an opera review and i'll
read an opera review and i'll be
enlightened by it i will never click on
the music section of the online times
and the other example it's coincidence
that Alex being just stepped forward
because I was going to use him as an
example is in the paper I read his
column I enjoy it I get pissed off by it
about half the time but because I
because he has good lead ins and good
headlines it usually draws me in but
because he pisses me off about half the
time I might not click to it and I might
not therefore get exposed to something
that would annoy me and I really mean
that as a compliment that you're
provocative and when you couple that
with Pablo's point about the
commodification and I just worry about
our culture becoming the lens through
which we view the world getting smaller
and smaller and flatter and flatter and
it doesn't just apply to news but it's
but but it certainly applies to news it
doesn't just apply this but it certainly
applies to news and none of the panaceas
that have been proposed have addressed
that concern for me sorry what that's
just a comment well I think it most
importantly actually applies to news
because it's ultimately news is how you
define your reality so if we're all
going to go out and get our different
pictures I mean we all have to some
extent of different picture of reality
but but if we all start going off and
completely just crazy divergent
directions democracy becomes much harder
because we can we're debating things
that should be facts right we do a live
with us now actually but you know it
could get much worse and I agree the the
serendipity factor i think is a big
point I I do a group that the one thing
about moving to online and i agree with
jerome that you're gonna you're going to
seek out the stories you want they are
still going to have that front page when
you go to the first page of that site
where they're going to try to tell you
something there'll be some chance maybe
that you'll get a little bit of
serendipity there but it's interesting
the New York Times new website has all
these tabs at the top and then I'll
functional yet but one of them is just
called my times and I assume this is
going to be some kind of some ability to
do do more customization it's not
functioning yet i'm curious to see
what's going to look like but but a
little bit of it would be lost on I mean
that's what I mean a little bit about
the news judgment of those people you
don't have to the nice thing about
online is you could still be able to see
some of it on that front page maybe not
as much you can a still ignore their
news judgment I mean believe me people
do all the time you know but I think
it's nice to have it out there just to
see what somebody else thinks is is
important Alex participating in politics
I think I see the you know the
definitely the creating of realities out
there that living by different realities
you can see it online you can see right
now with the story this breakin is Mark
Foley you can go to right-wing sites and
you just see a completely different
picture of reality than if you went to
progressive blogs where I tend to do
when I go into the mainstream media is
looking to see what you know what what
worldview are they buying into and it's
on one level it's a rather cynical
attitude but I think on another level
the participating nature of it means
that a lot more people are participating
in that political structure they might
be doing it from very partisan
perspectives are very oriented towards
their own needs but different democracy
usually is pretty pretty messy when a
lot of people get involved just keep it
online we'll be all right
can anyone one data point to your
comment I don't have figures for the
leading papers in the space but for the
two newspapers that they looked at and
it done extensive research on in
Argentina if you look at the total
number of clicks on any even day one
page it's between fifty and sixty
percent and that is the homepage so you
add these newspapers at every day a
hundred thousand pages available to
consumers the consumers click on one
fifty and sixty percent of the time
which means that they would they have a
day's notice on the Google they have
there is what they see fifty to sixty
percent of times of your concern Alison
if it is important important one because
what is not there likely will go and see
much more proportionally than in a world
of crane Alex beam perhaps I should
mention that Alex spoke at our first
forum he's a columnist for The Boston
Globe right I work for a newspaper I not
maybe not much longer though Alex I I
really my questions direct solely at
Jerome which is the reason I came here
and I wanted I totally empathize with
your comments about the lack of progress
progress civet e in the mainstream media
there's this it's it's almost complete
but can you talk to us for a while about
net roots and political power because I
feel like I've been on the receiving end
and I remember the excitement around
Dean and the online excitement around
Dean and it sort of faded out and I I
got really caught up in the Lamont thing
where net roots and it's sort of you
know outriders seem to have played a
fascinating role and now I'm there's
this possibility that Lamont might lose
to the Machine and night could you speak
for a while about progressive politics
and the Internet sure the you know when
i worked on howard dean's campaign up
and up in burlington and
after after he crashed and burned in in
Iowa there was a lot of stories like you
know is this a dot like a dot-com boom
or booze bus cycle of online netroots
politics and of course it wasn't you
know those people are still clicking
away and in fact much greater numbers
right now I think what we're seeing here
though is something that's going through
stages of growth and getting pushed back
from you know an establishment the for
me that the what's happened over then I
would largely say that this is what I
call the net roots movement has happened
this decade and it is increase in
numbers even in this last six months the
amount of people participating in the
blog's I mentioned it of the traffic
earlier at 120 million pageviews for the
month right now previous to lamont it
was at about 60 or 70 million so it's
nearly doubled in the last five or six
months I think the lamont race this was
ned lamont in connecticut who run won
the primary against joe lieberman really
showed that the the progressive movement
that is gathering steam online has the
power now to affect politics and
democratic party at the electoral level
and up to that point it had not been
possible the the reality comes crashing
in when you when you when you consider
that yes you can do it in the in the
primary election but the net roots are
probably not strong enough to do that at
the general election when independence
and and republicans are you know voting
justjust alongside the democrats so much
more partisan atmosphere but i don't
really view the the lamont election as a
do-or-die movement for the netroots
because i don't believe the net which is
going away this process that has started
online of people regaining control of
the Democratic Party engaging in
politics online is not going to go
anywhere it's going to stay with us and
whether or not lamont loses whether or
not the Democratic Party regains control
that's not going to change that's going
to keep going with this the the one
thing I'd like to point out though in
terms of like you know what's changed
over the last couple years is that in a
2003 cycle you had
a lot of big blogs that were more
nationally oriented towards the
presidential race this cycle what we're
seeing being developed a lot more is
what I call a local blogosphere and
these will be blogs that are within a
state and you have that here in
Massachusetts as a number of blogs it
that joined together and had a
conference called blog left late last
year and they've participated in a
number of other activities and so you
create this sort of local blogosphere
that exists within the you know the
wider progressive infrastructure but
it's part of a more local effort and in
what we're seeing now is that the
candidates are able to reach out to
these people and engage with them help
them with their turn out the vote
exercises and engage in politics on a
real grassroots on the ground level all
that is just you know from the
perspective of someone who likes it when
people get involved in politics just
great it's something that's going to be
with us till we say but you know the ups
and downs of the victories and whatnot
are going to stick around with this and
any follow-up far is that sort of along
the discussion okay I have a question
it's sort of a full of the question what
our newspapers what is a newspaper and
get me thinking what what is the
audience about I don't know it's been
over ten years ago I was in this
building doing research on customized
news as part of a research program
called the news using the future program
and at the time talking about the deli
me and customized news was very
criticized and we were talking about the
loss of serendipity and but now many
years have passed and I'm still
wondering what is audience when you say
that newspapers have editors who have an
expertise in identifying stories
but that's because they are they
identify the stories based on an
audience and to target a certain
audience but then how do you define
audience it seems like audience is
something very diverse and hard to like
i was born in colombia i grew up in
france and I'm here now and I'm
interested in all those countries but I
and I'm not saying I'm representative
but I'm just saying everybody has a
different background I need for an
interest so I'll start off in this for
what you know this points out earlier is
what is lost is you know with this
customized news trend that we're having
what is lost is a centralized sort of
broadcast messages going out there to
people and and I don't really blame I
mean it sort of sounds like we're kind
of victimizing you know that the
broadcast medium thing but I think you
know Pablo pointed out did the problem
that was was created with this in in the
beginning because they were not
delivering what people wanted they were
they were delivering more of something
that's been commodified for consumption
in an easy will recognizable focus and
from a political standpoint they were
creating things that were advocating
something that was what I've you have a
lot of times be right wing propaganda
because they were reading so pressured
by those forces that wanted to control
the debate I guess the thing I'd say
about about editors and and expertise
and and whatnot is I don't I usually I
think when you it depends on the news
organization but if you get to the right
news organization I don't think that
they put stories on the front page for
their audience i think maybe they'll put
one story on the front page at the crowd
pleaser or something like that but if
you've looked at the front page of like
of the globe or The Times The Washington
Post those stories are up there because
a bunch of people all SAT around and
it's not that they're not that they're
experts on everything but they have all
these people you know coming back to the
saying this is going on Ryan this is
going on where I am this is going on
Miami it's like well why is that
important why is that important why is
that important and they sit and they
they take all that into account they're
like based on everything I've heard
these are the five biggest stories of
today you know and maybe plus the story
about a lost dog or something that a
little get that truly is there just like
you know it's a it's a good read
blazer but I really don't think that
they put the stores in the front page
just because they're trying to attract
audience I think that they're doing it
because they think this isn't true of
all places and actually I would say this
it's less true in broadcast and that's
probably my bias as a print guy but but
I really do think when they put those
front pages together they're there
they're putting the stories upload they
think are the most important that is for
the most part putting themselves in the
position of the earth what I would like
to read a lot veteran center and they
are a very special kind of policy that
way and to a certain extent the news
that they produce that they communicate
reflects their own self perception of an
intended audience so one two it is an
alicorn I think that's not to say that
those papers are not here do not exist
in society to tell us what we want
necessarily but we should know right
that we may not clear about that is
important that a citizens of a
particular country or people who live in
a particular locality we should know and
that's a very very important function
that they play now in the world in which
many craters in the states ninety-seven
percent of newspapers operate in natural
monopolies markets that is they have no
other local competitor right and in
which newspaper people get aggregated
circulation figures about how much they
are selling and they making some
information in terms of focus groups
about what people want to know and so
they are very gay and aggregate like a
real conception of the audience of the
earlier if you spot it is easier to
sustain this mission of saying I'm gonna
tell you what you should know not
necessary
to my own online they have klicks right
right okay everybody clicks and
everybody goes with your clicks and
people online and all the time you're
only monitoring their composition but
how well or badly your stories are doing
and they are developing a much more
refined taste matter if i sell some sort
of the taste of the audience and so for
instance newspaper newspapers each other
for the top stories think that tends to
be a heavy proportion of public affairs
for like national for etcetera most of
what consumers want to read about as
mission in terms of their clicks sports
entertainment right natural disasters
etc one thing is when you have that
vague idea the focus group service that
you don't see every day with the
clicking on your stories but when you
see that information every day right it
creates a very important conflict that
is pervasive in all the new ships that i
visited on the depot director to which
is between the daily New York
aggregation of the Bellamy has
manifested in their cliques and the
professional values right and the sense
of purpose and the public service of the
journalism profession which is a
wonderful thing right so part of what's
going on is that right I mean it is true
that the audience recommend is a very
complicated constructed center today but
these technological changes in part and
intentionally have revealed a certain
dynamic right that is much more
difficult to avoid now that what it was
before and again for organizations you
want to google news yahoo etc etc we do
not have is wonderful journalistic
values they are for Devin and delivered
whole lot of what the audience was an
unnecessary
right it's like easier to move in that
direction but for for tradition and
media is much more difficult because the
citizens values so it is a very
complicated issue let me mention people
that I know some people have already
left and we're going to have a very
elegant reception after this event
starting at seven o'clock all of you who
are here are certainly invited and I
hope you'll attend question yeah I guess
two questions I is the traditional media
seating their expertise to make
editorial judgment when they start
feeding off each other you know who
decides what a story is if everyone says
pointing at each other saying we don't
have it we need to have that do they
suddenly stop exercising judgment and on
the side of that you know Jerome you
talk about the ex the two tiers of
expertise the familiar and then the
authoritarian expertise in the
blogosphere how do we vet experts how do
we say this guy really knows what he's
talking about about Southeast Asia
versus this person start with that last
part I think it comes through the
experts are basically known to their
credibility and it you know the the
unique thing about the Internet is
history sort of begins in the mid-1990s
and you can you can go um you know if
you have online record that's associated
with you people can find out about it in
the book so much jewel is the online
record associated with them I mean so
many people post anonymously oh yeah
well then you're yeah well so then you
either are pretty skeptical of that
thing that's posted and that's sort of
evolved over time it used to be that you
know when things would break people were
reported no matter who did the story and
it was part of the cycle but people got
burned a couple times especially um you
know people that were out there under
their name who were taking anonymous
statements at their at their face value
that's I think that's evolved over time
and especially from the perspective
Dante can speak to this of a journalist
that reaching out there there's there's
a much more skepticism that exists
online now but there is a you know the
editorial judgment that you mentioned
you know I see this playing out right
now with the with the mark foley scandal
in it there's a lot of online blogs and
websites that are reporting on who the
pages actually wore these are minors
that were involved with Mark Foley these
in it's very explicit you have pictures
of the people you have descriptions of
where their jobs are now and everything
everything down to the detail it isn't
making it into the wider mainstream
media and I think that and it's not even
making a low larger blogosphere but it's
definitely out there so you have
something of a you know we think it tend
to see the blogs is sort of like a
gatekeeper are having busted down the
gatekeeper the presence of the
mainstream media but it's still very
much in effective for sometimes like
this case good recent I think there'll
always be gatekeepers I mean it's just
gonna be who's who said you know it's
just who is that the gate you know
somebody's going to be there and maybe
the gates bigger or smaller or whatever
whatnot the the Pablo study is really
interesting about about about Argentina
just because it's it's the I think the
thing it most again the thing that most
ties to United States is local
television because you have a market
where you'll generally have at least
three maybe four stations doing the news
at the same time and you talk to
somebody who's done local TV news and
they're watching the other newscast the
entire time and writing down what's on
there in the morning they get the
ratings they get the overnights the next
morning like oh my god this story didn't
do well why did this do this we've got
to move something out it it is a
different I mean it works different than
a newspaper it is much more of a
commodity local television news than
newspapers are just because it's the
environment in existent and it's
troubling if that's if that becomes the
the way online starts to operate because
it's a very bad in terms of news
judgment is just awful it's gonna it's
gonna it will things will get
commodified and it'll lead to a dumbing
down this is part of the problem though
there that I mean in terms of what we're
talking about tonight the thirty percent
of people are online in Argentina and if
that wouldn't number were higher I
wonder if we would have these problems
that you're you're describing
I want to make one epithet why because
people wouldn't i mean i think if those
papers had a lot more competition with
online sources where their eyeballs
removing though after them that they
wouldn't necessarily be replicating
their stories because if they're going
to start printing the same thing it
leaves a huge vacuum out there for other
people to go into okay so um editorial
judgment is always a collective
enterprise make all kinds of judgment so
the social device is not that is not
composed Newsom has more than one person
and that and that judgment actions have
resulted fear so on the job
socialization in some cases professional
training etc etc what has been happening
though is that the collective character
judgment right is there's always a
tension between the collective and
individual organizational right what's
going on is that there is more fun in
terminus ational convergence that is
leading to this judgment being more
share right so they has always been a
connected component now is more likely
than before but it's not that it wasn't
collected before 12 2 that is very
important in this context the role of
the wire services becomes even more
important because a greater proportion
of what we see in the online press known
and environment comes actually from the
wireless and actually what happens that
the people in the new sooner or later
people in the other news were watching
each other people the premium are
watching about the online are doing
right sometimes I've been told I hadn't
observed this directly so I don't have
systematic data but
seven instead of regarding a noose
budget by themselves the action re grab
brings out a couple of online penalties
from reputable sources sometimes and I
newspaper something LOL a newspaper and
they take that to the noon meeting so
because again is easier to access that
information and time constraints of a
very safe so two things that thing a
happy is that the collective dimension
of the notorious judgment is still a
little later because of a thousand
possible story started five six seven
ten stories I've been chosen so that is
the expression of judging but the
collective part right is more important
than before and in a context in which
the recess from ross's differences and
the people at the project for excellence
in journalism as we have written a lot
maybe the in which the acceleration of
the new cycle has deepened is less time
it settles again then reliance on wire
services it's been greater than before
we also related weather is good but now
is even greater so again guys adding to
the collective right nature of the
enterprise I'm going to your comment it
is so what one way of thinking about it
is it is not only that is twenty five
percent but it also that twenty-five
percent represents disproportionately a
particular segment in the socio-economic
so as I mean we have the upper tier
because in a country with no notice of
cover together and creating high I
people who had access the web etc etc so
one would think it's not only that the
pie if the pie gets bigger than more
resources manager he probably gets more
diverse they should be more I don't know
that what I do know what I do know is so
remember i said i have data from 2004
2005 and i have so basically the 2 i'm
much more alike than before them and i
said we need there is a growth between 0
4 and 0 5 in the convergence right so
what we see is that the convergence as
all right ah but at the same time the
amount of people who access the internet
have grown as well and the spreading in
social anomie here army has gone down
too so it's actually at least from this
very little that i have is exactly the
opposite of what you're saying right i
don't know i mean it's just two years
it's very little variation but then i'm
not sure you go you may be right not
sure you go that way I would just I
would just say I hope you're right I
hope Jerome's right but my concern is
that ultimately it's the it's the ad
dollars that are going to determine it
and that's a problem because the
advertisers they're just going to care
about a certain population it becomes a
problem but I hope I hope you're right
not the carrier question I have a
comment about the somebody say about the
demo democracy of effects and reality
considering the political implement
implications of mainstream media how do
you comment on how much freedom has it
offered to a certain geographical area
especially in the area where a lot of
news our sensor or a lot of facts or
realities our sensor or interpreted in a
certain ways especially in China or here
in the United States how it going to
affect the third parties who don't
really have any voices in in the
mainstream media it's really interesting
you say that the last column I wrote for
The Christian Science Monitor was after
i just had met he was over here in a
State Department fellowship he was a
blogger from china who word for China
Daily which I thought was insane because
obviously all the media in China is
controlled by the Chinese government
like what can you possibly be putting up
and he says well we allow we photos
everybody you know it's you know it's no
different than us everybody's got camera
phones so they're going out and they're
snapping pictures of the camera phones
they
right a couple lines of text they send
it to us and we posted our website I was
like this is this is fascinating you
know how do you choose you know what
what happens then what we choose what
goes on the front page and and I said
what do you do with controversial topics
and he said they've told me the
government has told me they're very
excited by what I'm doing but be careful
that was what they said and he said that
everybody has an individual page they
kind of have their own photo blog and if
they have not issued him they had not
issued him rules for what he would do
with taking pictures of things that are
technically illegal like strikes he
could take a picture of a strike he
could put he now they would not let him
post it on the front page but the idea
is this person could post it on their
personal blog and I thought this is
remarkable and in two weeks it had only
been up for two weeks it that you know
the you the number of people sending in
photos this was was was you know it was
it was shooting up and heat and I went
and I looked at the site and I thought
it was really fascinating i wrote about
wrote about it in a column i wrote about
it on a saturday after looking at the
website when the column came out on
tuesday the website had been taken down
and it's not it's I wasn't worried that
I'd done something it wasn't that there
there are things going on in China right
now there's another shake-up going on
and and and there is there's going to be
some country there there there were
definite media the person who is getting
more control wants more controlled the
media so he obviously shut this thing
down at least I think it's shut down it
says it's been it's been down for server
maintenance now for like 10 days okay
but but the thing I thought when I wrote
the column was this once they let in the
camera phones to me the fights over at
some point whether you post those on a
blog or whatever some of those pictures
are going to get out I mean I I think
you know that they're gonna they're
going to try to maintain the tightest
control they can over the media you know
but but I think that you know this is
the good this is the this is the best
part of blogging this is the best part
of citizen journalism system journalism
at its
best they won't be able to control it
and things are going to come out and
eventually it's it's it's it's going to
be hard and it's going to be hard fought
battle maintain control as tight as I
can but eventually they'll lose control
there's one there's one topic that
really hasn't been much discussed in our
in our three forum so far and it's been
an implicit or embedded in in some of
the comments that have been made to
today and I'm wondering if we can get
some comments from the panel that may be
from the audience about it and that to
put it in its simplest form is the
tradition of political independence that
is true of Western newspapers and
especially of American newspapers there
is no in all of the complaints that one
hears about the top-down media and the
mainstream media it's very and of course
there is is true that the mainstream
media the Washington Post The New York
Times promulgate certain in their
editorials and in their news stories
promulgate certain perspectives on the
world there's no question about that but
they also themselves believe themselves
to be committed to a different kind of
aesthetic or moral mission and that
mission is to sort of tell the truth as
they understand it to a citizenry that
needs to hear these truths and what
those journalists do is protect it
constitutionally in the United States a
lot of other societies don't have that
and that constitutional protection as
everyone knows does not extend to other
media television news isn't completely
protected in the same way there's no
evidence that that online news will be
protected in the same way so the
question I want you to address in one
sense is leave aside the feelings of any
particular newspaper is there some ideal
of what journalism is embedded in
democratic societies and especially in
the constitutionally protected rights of
newspapers in the United States that
should be protected should be celebrated
should we that we should try to find a
way of extending these principles into
the into emerging media isn't this a
loss if it's not the K if we if we don't
recognize that what they're like the
idea I think one of them that's um been
brought up here which is very relevant
to this discussion
is the being openness to information
that you would have otherwise not might
have clicked on on the internet somebody
brought this up recent earlier with the
with the Opera review and I think that's
something to think about and but also
the the notional on the on the web that
you're totally closed off is it's
probably not the case because if you
consider what we're talking about with
China there's a reason why they don't
want to let the people to get out on the
web is because you learn about much more
different viewpoints than you would have
otherwise certainly there's places in
the United States even work you know we
have pockets of culture that are
newspapers which would have probably
established fact as creationism with
their readers I mean it's just a fact of
where you know where we live in today at
the United States and those same people
they go online they might only go to
creationists type of websites but
they're going to be exposed if they
click around a lot to different
viewpoints there are different
traditions of the press when it comes to
the relationship
between the press in China newspapers
online depressed in general journalism
and the stage and politics right and
there are different manifestations of
democracy there are different ways there
is not just one kind of democracies
different kinds of democracy and one of
the main contributions that the pressing
dif different traditions have see is
that in general the state and large
corporations etcetera try to control the
news agenda or obvious reasons right so
I will find a resourceful autonomous
press as always tried other ways to
control to monitor right impart industr
right by providing a product that is
different but doing more and more
investigation more and more that's all
the way of bringing this up is because
this trail towards the commodification
is actually decreasing the contribution
that the press room has right as a
collective actor in different democratic
societies and that's why it's a very
it's not just a bit difficult and
obsessed by decisions and thinking about
this and trying to collect data make
sense of it I think its importance is
socially relevant because it is an
apology for all of us yes I mean pebbles
findings have a paradoxical contact
quality obviously I mean because if the
net is supposed to be so liberating and
pluralist and pluralistic yet if its
effect on news is to make news less
pluralistic that's very disturbing and
very strange it's obviously a very very
interesting project and the paper is
certainly going to be something i want
to read closely Henry yeah I I guess
you've succeeded in provoking me David
to respond and I was resisting doing so
but your statement my intention the
statement that the First Amendment
belongs to professional journalist is a
pretty outrageous statement well I
didn't say I mean here you as I said I
said I said the press I said the press
in the United States is protected by the
First Amendment and you said others
people are not protected but in fact
point of that is a right of political
participation our founding fathers would
certainly have been shocked to discover
that it was professional journalist who
had some sort of monopolies but it's
congress to read Henry not me its
Congress that did that I mean there have
been decisions that have not allowed the
freedom that it goes to to press to
print papers to be applied in other
media it should be of course well is it
there's all I I think I think that's an
illegal wrecker it is the legal record
is really would be disputed on that and
I think it's much more important for us
to insist the rights of citizen
journalists and bloggers are protected
from the First Amendment than they
accept the premise that there's some
sort of exclusive right of professional
the control freak was not my I hope that
was not my assumption my assumption was
what the law is actually know like I
don't think I agree review about where
the law is on that day but then that's
the part of the problem well the one
thing is that the one thing as
journalists do have a special
responsibility and democracy because you
can write anything you want and you can
write what you want on the web but the
fact of the matter there when you're a
journalist you you actually you know and
you are aid you're paid to do your job
which is the big thing about paying to
be your job as you are accredited yes
that means that some government person
is saying that you are allowed to do
things but unfortunately not everybody
can go through Congress and just like go
up to the press gallery because it
wouldn't be big enough you know not
everybody can you know sit in the White
House press room most people probably
wouldn't want to but but but you know
it's it's there there are special
responsibilities involved in being a
journalist and and and you know the
democracy can't function properly
without without journalists doing their
jobs because look they're the ones who
have access to these people and you
might have had questions you want to ask
george bush before the war and a lot of
people might have questions but they
weren't going to get to do it it was the
people who had the credentials who were
going to get to do it and you know they
didn't do it properly a lot of people
would say and they'd probably be right
so there there's there is something
special about the the right about the
the rights that are granted to
accredited journalist to do things not
to say what they're going to say but to
have access to things that you don't
have access
no Henry I would maybe I just wasn't
clear i mean you've misunderstood me i
did not at all want to imply that i
didn't think these rights should extend
era of course I do but I my
understanding is that legally in the
United States television news does not
have told the same complete freedom that
the print papers do that that that there
have that there have been I don't know
if they're been Supreme Court decisions
but there have been decisions about how
to apply questions of freedom of the
press and and First Amendment freedoms
that have not been extended to other
media I think they should be extended to
other media I think that the idea of the
First Amendment should apply to all
forms of to all forms of communication
of course I would not want it it
restricted in any way but in practice
it's not been the case in and and it's
also obvious that in practice television
news has not behaved in the same in the
same way taking the same kind of
attitude toward its relation to to tour
government for example a tort tort its
role as reporting as print papers have
of course I hope that in in the online
world that is emerging that there will
be a citizen journalists who will assert
the same powers and and rights of
inquiry no question I certainly think
that that should happen it ought to
happen the FEC this year had a ruling
come down with the with the political
blogger spirit it was advocated by a
bunch of regulatory pro regulatory aidan
organizations in DC that the
participation in the political process
by blogs which were openly partisan be
viewed as in-kind contributions and
especially for the links that they put
out onto the you know contribute to
these candidates now type of things and
ultimately the FEC found that that there
was no way that they could write such
sort of legislation for bloggers alone
and they sort of threw that out rightly
so because you know the what we're doing
what political bloggers are doing in on
the online world is no different than
what you're doing when you go and talk
to other people that they have a wider
audience that listens to them is not
their choice when they participate in
the dialogue or what can I ask a
question here
sure but I want to ask question just
following up with Dante is is the access
that the the press has is it granted
though because of the respect for those
for their you know their rights and in
their position in their their ability to
hopefully look at things objectively or
is it granted because of the audience's
they reach in the persuasion power that
they have ultimately it's granted
because the because the First Amendment
is in the Constitution because they felt
that for the government to work well
somebody had to tell everybody what was
going on the government and it's just
you know it people have people get paid
to do this specific thing to go and
report on things and and not everybody
can have access to just to walk into two
buildings and press conferences I mean
it literally is a question of it
literally as a matter of you know just
logistics to be honest I really think
it's you know it's in bloggers I mean
bloggers were invited and and they will
increasingly be invited they'll be
invited to do more and more stuff but
but when they do that they will be
accepting the fact that they are in some
ways becoming more like mainstream
journalists that's that's that's part of
the that's part of the deal and I and I
don't think it's I don't think it's
about the fact that they're not that
they're not biased i mean the National
Review you know the nation these people
get press credentials as well I I don't
think you can separate though from the
fact that they they have audiences that
they're they're open to persuasion with
if it's a nation didn't have any readers
at all I doubt that they would get as
much access I think that's fair that's
that's also that's a question of when
you have that's the same question is if
you've got you know 20 candidates who
are running for the Democratic
nomination but but really there's only
four that have a legitimate shot at
winning and maybe they invite eight and
the 12 or you know the LaRouche people
stand in the balcony and yell down at
people about how unfair everything is it
you know it's just the lines are drawn
at some point and it's it is to some
extent you're right yeah there's a
constituency for the for the for those
candidates as constituents you for those
media yeah it's well the communications
forum has entered a conversation about
newspapers that's been going on in the
Society for a long time and we'll go on
after our forums are over I hope at
least some of the things that have been
said have been productive of further
thought I want to thank the audience and
I thank our panel
you